working out has been a huge part of my
life I try to do it as much as I can at
least three times a week I'll do usually
three days of cardio and three days of
strength I'm a competitive crossfitter I
work out ten or eleven hours a week for
the last four years I've been an Olympic
weightlifter hopefully I don't I don't
pass out I don't want to get runners
diarrhea what if I trip what if I'm not
fast anymore what if I'm too old
best-case scenario I beat all the other
girls worst case scenario I fail
completely and make a fool out of myself
the physical fitness test is
administered according to very strict
FBI protocols to attain a passing score
on the PFT you must earn at least one
point in each of the four events and at
least a cumulative score of 12 points
event one situps to be done in one
minute event to 300 meter dash event
three push-ups to be done without
stopping event for one and a half mile
run
one
sit-ups for time is a lot harder than I
thought it would be I think I did it
right I was bouncing pretty hard off the
ground I think I got some momentum from
that it wasn't too bad I was very
focused throughout and I feel like I'm
ready for the next challenge I went
through a range of emotions like I'd be
like I'm crushing it oh my god there's
so much time left
oh now I'm slowing now I'm crushing it
again
I went fast out of the gate and then I
was like this is a bad idea
halfway mark
Candis coat I'm dying I felt good like I
went out kind of easier here and then
just turn it on right by pretty close so
I was like am I even running in a
straight direction anymore
it was pretty easy because apparently
FBI push-ups are only half the range of
motion compared to the push-ups I
normally do maybe if I did the correct
for motive been harder like like screwed
it up I think it was pretty easy they
felt really different cuz I normally do
my push-ups really close here so I felt
them a lot in a different part of my arm
I have a weak upper body and I knew that
this wasn't going to be fun
I think that that slope that first slope
really hit me in my glutes and I felt
like I wasn't going to make it but I
kept a consistent pace and having the
music is really helpful to get through
it at some point I had to stop and walk
a little but then I instead of getting
defeated I remembered how when I did
marathon training that even like a short
rest gives you so much more energy and
then I was able to like take off and
finish the run I'm actually very shocked
that I did that in that amount of time
because I usually run like a 10-minute
mile I think I was just terrified of
failing and that first hill was so steep
and I was never the same again but that
being said this was actually my fastest
mile pace I've run in years
so I passed I feel good about it I'm
slightly surprised I really thought I
was gonna fail on that mile and a half
run so I'm glad that I didn't I'm kind
of proud of myself I think I did pretty
well
FBI fitness test wasn't as challenging
as I thought it was gonna be it does
make me a little sad that I was able to
crush the FBI test and makes me wonder
if they shouldn't have a little a little
higher benchmark now that I passed this
I kind of feel unstoppable I feel like I
should be in a James Bond movie or
something to celebrate
I'm gonna have some ice cream and I'm
gonna go work out in the morning feeling
pretty good about myself